know who Andrew taters yes of course and  do you like him no why  um I don't know he says some pretty  harsh things about women what did he say  um I don't know just things are like um  I don't know I don't know specifics I  can't get into the specifics I don't  know right now so how can you not like  someone if you can't give me an example  that's a good question he once said that  women are the most precious thing on the  planet what's your take I don't know I  don't like that I feel like yeah we're  strong we're precious and we're strong  so I feel like him saying we're precious  is kind of like dimming down our  strength so I didn't really like that he  thinks like a man should provide for a  woman what do you think about that I  think women can also provide for  ourselves you know what a man that can  provide for you I want to provide for me  and then he can spoil me